en tunisie des manifestations de
citoyens se poursuivre sans relâche
depuis deux semaines
cela se passe dans une région très
pauvre du centre du pays à kaffrine où
le taux de chômage s'élève à plus de 40%
environ 200 personnes occupent jour et
nuit une petite place devant le siège du
gouvernorat de kasserine qui leur ont
apporté leur diplôme d'études d'autres
leur carnet de santé
ils réclament un emploi et il juge que
c'est l'état qui doit leur fournir les
plus exaspérés et c'est parfois de
forcer le cordon militaire en exigeant
de parler aux gouverneurs la colère
gronde depuis longtemps à kaffrine il ya
eu de nombreux soulèvements populaires
ici avant pendant et après la révolution
de 2010 qui a entraîné le départ du
président ben ali
ce mouvement de protestation représente
une véritable bombe à retardement pour
le gouvernement tunisien
déjà aux prises avec une baisse de
revenus grave et la menace terroriste
régional